I would like to feel that my work has
impact in the world but I I also need to
approach this question with a certain
degree of humility I mean we at Harvard
sometimes think that we're part of the
greatest university in the world but
there are lots of other places now that
are also doing great things my work if I
have influenced some people some people
in leadership positions to do things
differently that's the important thing I
do have many many people who read my
books they quote me I'm sometimes
recognized in airports but I also sit in
meetings with world leaders where I am
convinced of my utter irrelevance so I
think that I have had an impact in terms
of the term empowerment and the
importance of empowering people I think
my work on change has guided many many
organizations not only through my books
but through a change toolkit on the
worldwide web that is being used by many
companies and governments around the
world I think that the ideas have
entered into the vocabulary of
leadership so much so that people
sometimes forget that I thought of it
first and I guess that's what's
important because I'm going to go on to
the next idea
oh my proudest achievement it is so hard
to say my proudest achievement is
generally the most recent because
because I have just put in so much
effort and so much struggle to do it I
really work hard none of it comes easy
so I think of my books as proud
achievements but I'm always proudest of
the most recent because I think that
I've gone further in whatever that is
I'm certainly proud of my son
of of being able to have a life
sufficiently balanced that I could have
a good family life and and set forth my
son upon the world I'm certainly proud
of of the companies I've changed of the
ideas I've spawned and I could point to
particular ones of the presidential
campaigns that I've influenced of the
world leaders with whom I've shared the
stage and numerous events who had
already been using my ideas but then go
back and have learned something that
often shapes their agenda I'm asked
questions like well what should be the
most important priority for Colombia and
I answer those questions
so it's thought leadership it's working
with the power of ideas and it's
wonderful that in this world of giant
enterprises iBM has 350,000 people an
enormous lis advanced technology and yet
one person whispering in the ear of a
world leader or an IBM executive can
often change the course of that company
and sometimes the course of history
women in business as well as women in
leadership positions in any sector have
been something that I've been very
concerned about my entire professional
life and I have to say it was selfish
because I got my PhD at a time when
there were very few people like me I was
often the first of my kind sitting in a
room with people of another kind that
sometimes true by the way when I go as
an American to the Middle East now where
I'm very different in many respects so I
was very concerned about getting more
women I thought it was in my
self-interest to have my women
colleagues first of all then the whole
image of women would would have been
elevated but also I wouldn't have had to
sit there and answer silly questions
about what's the woman's point of view
there I wanted more at the table I also
do care about opportunity and I care
about not breaking not being confined I
care about I care about opportunity and
I care about not being trapped behind
stereotypes so now we've had the
breakthroughs there's certainly more
women in leadership positions and lots
and lots of women in the pipeline what
I'm concerned about now is that we
haven't changed institutions enough to
make it possible for women who want to
devote themselves to their children
during formative years to do that or for
men for that matter who say no I'd like
to devote my time to my children to do
that without feeling they sacrifice
their careers I think we still don't
have enough women in leadership to make
it totally normal or we wouldn't ask
today's silly woman question which is
was Carly Fiorina fired because she was
a woman and the answer is no she wasn't
but all the attention she got afterwards
was because we had so few women CEOs we
didn't take it for granted but I think
we have to get more women in leadership
in order to do that we need to help
those talented women in the pipeline
feel that they can continue to advance
without sacrificing important things to
them in life they don't have to
sacrifice their career nor do they have
to sacrifice their family I think that
more men ought to take on some of those
family responsibilities that was
important to me I always felt there was
a reason for two parents and my husband
did a great deal and so we could lead
more balanced lives I think that to me
is the frontier is what we do about work
and family work-life balance and if we
crack that we will see all those
talented women taking on
responsibilities and it will look
completely normal to have women do
important leadership tasks